white house chief of staff mark meadows
says the united states cannot control
the coveted pandemic gavin newsom rolls
out insane new thanksgiving restrictions
in california
and the left tries to manipulate social
media into censoring conservatives i'm
ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
today's ben shapiro show is sponsored by
expressvpn your online activity
shouldn't be public protect yourself at
expressvpn.com we'll get into
everything news related in just one
moment but first
we are approaching black friday and
don't you wish that everyday shopping
was like
black friday well good news when it
comes to your cell phone bill it
basically is cause all you have to do is
switch over to pure talk
usa verizon at t t-mobile if you're with
them you're overpaying
pure and simple pure talk can easily
save you over 400
per year listen here's what you need
unlimited talk text and two gigs of data
for just 20 bucks a month and if you go
over on data usage they don't charge you
for it see here's the thing those big
cellular companies they're charging you
for unlimited data you don't need
unlimited data
in all likelihood instead what you need
is like two gigs of data and again if
you go over a little bit it's not that
big a deal switching to pure talk it's
the easiest decision
you will make today you can keep your
phone and your number or get great deals
on the latest iphones and android grab
your mobile phone
dial pound 250 say my name ben shapiro
when you do you save 50
off your first month dial pound 2 5 0
say keyword ben
shapiro pure talk is simply smarter
wireless no reason for you to spend too
much on your cell phone bill instead
head on over and dial pound 250 and say
ben shapiro to get started with pure
talk
usa you'll save 50 off your first month
and hundreds more
over the course of the ensuing months to
come alrighty so
it's now past the debate we are in the
home stretch here we have eight days
until the election and right now the
polling for president trump
remains not great nationally and it
remains fairly competitive
in a lot of the swing states so
basically this election comes down to
seven or eight states it comes down to
arizona north carolina florida all of
which trump must win
and then it also comes down to michigan
pennsylvania wisconsin
maybe iowa right trump needs to win iowa
and he needs to win at least one of
those others
so trump has a bit of a tall task in
front of him right now the polls show in
the real
politics national average joe biden up
by about eight points the race seems to
be extremely stable
florida biden and trump are running
essentially dead even
according to a couple of new polls trump
and biden are running very close in
arizona they're running very close in
north carolina when you get
into the upper midwest once you start
getting into that so-called blue wall
that hillary clinton had breached by
trump in a major way in
2016 then the gaps start to look a
little bit larger
wisconsin is starting to come down in
terms of joe biden's lead
so if you look at the polls in wisconsin
biden right now is up approximately 4.6
in the net in the real clear politics
polling average
he was up closer eight to ten the latest
poll from
fox news has biden up about five 49 to
in wisconsin that one was taken at the
end of last week
if you look at michigan michigan is the
one that looks most out of reach that
one is close to eight points and if you
look at pennsylvania
joe biden has about a five point lead in
pennsylvania so
trump needs to win one of those three
states now the good news for trump is
that in pennsylvania there are a couple
of polls that have him within
three so the last three polls in
pennsylvania have biden up
two three and five respectively so this
is still a close election in the swing
states even if it is not particularly
close
nationally and that means that as we
approach the election democrats are
trotting out their final appeal
their final appeal is covid and it
always was coveted because it turns out
that president trump's record up until
the point that covet hit
was really really good and put aside his
rhetoric which made a lot of people
uncomfortable right left and center
put aside the tweets put aside the silly
statements when it came to can we deal
with the silly statements most americans
were willing to treat the presidency
like a plumber what your plumber says
doesn't matter the question is can you
fix your toilet
well as of february early march people
were like okay well so
my my plumber kind of crude sometimes
shows his butt crack but at least he
fixed my toilet right my toilet's
running great
right now i got a you know i had a clog
in the shower he came in he unclogged
the shower and everything's hunky-dory
sure i wouldn't want him babysitting my
kids per se his hygiene may not be the
best but the bottom line is that
everything is now running in a way that
it was not running before right that was
i think the generalized take on trump
up until about february then covet hits
and things stop running
and not only do things stop running then
all of the crudities
and the oddities seem to make a
difference to the american people
because the american people suddenly
want from their president something more
than making things run on time
they want the president to be a
comforter in chief as joe biden likes to
call himself they want the president to
be somebody who's going to empathize
with them and show feelings and
all this sort of stuff which is not
trump's mainstay
now that in and of itself would not be
a killer app when it comes to trump
because trump is trump and we all know
that trump is trump
the killer app when it comes to trump
and democrats know this is that they
have to promulgate
an extraordinary lie and the lie is that
trump is responsible for everybody who
died from coven
that the trump administration boxed this
in a way no other country did
this is the great lie and they keep
putting it out there over and over and
over
a couple of weeks ago i cut a video
about president trump
in which i said i was going to vote for
him in 2020 even though i didn't vote
for him in 2016 i explained
all the reasons why and in the video i
mentioned kovid
only to the extent that i said that i
was impressed that trump had gotten the
resources where they needed to be
and also that trump had not used the
power at hand
in order to centralize more power in the
federal government he had allowed
localism
to rule he allowed round desantis to be
around desantis he allowed andrew cuomo
for better or worse to be andrew cuomo
the bottom line is we live in a
federalist country we live in a country
where rule is supposed to be chiefly
done at the local level and not at the
very top level
and trump had i think wisely and
actually bravely
refused to grab control from the top now
folks on the left
saw that as a flaw because they love top
down control top down control is their
favorite thing in terms of what
government can do
and this was the greatest excuse for top
down control in the history of the
nation so at the same time they were
calling trump a vicious fascist
they were also calling for trump to take
control of virtually every production
facility
that he could get his hands on via the
national defense act the national
defense authorization act
so you know all of that trump refused to
do and i said that was good thing so i
started getting calls
from members of the media saying why
didn't you talk about trump's record on
kovid more
in that particular video why weren't you
talking so much about trump's record on
covet
and i said because i don't think that
any single politician anywhere on planet
earth has a good handle on covet
i don't think that that the leader of
new zealand has a great handle on covet
i think that she lives on an island with
more sheep than people
i i do not think that the leaders of
western europe have a good handle
on this thing because literally not one
of those nations has not experienced a
spike and we are now watching a spike in
places that heretofore had not seen one
places like germany we're seeing a
second spike in places like italy
italy had done heavy lockdowns and by
the way in early october
mandatory masking outside and they are
still seeing a massive spike
it turns out that when it comes to a
novel coronavirus there is not a
fantastic way to handle a novel
coronavirus that is heavily seated
if you can get a hold of it before it's
heavily seated that's one thing but the
fact is this thing was widely seeded in
the united states
as of february as studies are now
showing it may have been in the united
states as early as early january
and it started to race across the
country incredibly fast and it didn't
just start to race across america it
started to race across
every western european and northern
european country
and then the numbers across europe right
now are much worse than the numbers
in the united states in terms of the the
number of daily infections
you can see the spike the spike is
enormous in europe right now is that
trump's fault
the answer of course is no and what i
kept pointing out is the democrats had
no different policy
the only policy the democrats have
brought to bear is lockdown policy
lockdown policy is not sustainable at a
certain point you have to let up the
lockdown so that people can live their
lives
and when that happens there will be
spread and the only thing that you can
do
is mitigation the only thing that you
can do is try to protect the vulnerable
and protect the elderly which means
social distancing
and mask wearing and that's pretty much
it and if you are elderly and if you
feel you have an underlying condition
you need to stay home as much as humanly
possible
that's all you can do there are no there
are no solutions here
there are some therapeutics that are
better than they were a few months ago
we know how to treat this thing better
in hospitals a lot better in hospitals
than we did
back in march the death rates on covet
are down about 80 in hospitals
and they have been for several months
here which is why you're seeing this
massive spike in cases but not this
massive spike in deaths
in the united states you have this big
spike in cases the number of daily
deaths remains around a thousand a day
which is horrible and
which is tragic but i'm not sure that
it's supremely avoidable given the fact
that we do not have a vaccine for this
thing nor do we have a therapeutic that
radically reduces the mortality rate
of the disease thus far but that's not
just true of the united states that's
true in europe as well
in other words what democrats in the
media have been trying to do is create a
point of differentiation with regard to
trump's performance
that does not exist there is no
democratic plan to stop covet
there is not there is no democratic plan
that makes kovid
less deadly there isn't there is no
democratic plan
to prevent the spread of coveted utterly
and if you think that
full lockdown is going to spread the
stop the spread of covet utterly
then what is your plan for shutting down
the entire american economy for another
year
for another year particularly since
covet is not threatening
to people who are under the age of 20.
it is less threatening than the flu for
people who are under the age of 20
and for people who are under the age of
50 it is marginally more threatening
than the flu when i say it's marginally
more threatening i mean it might be
twice as deadly as the flu but the flu
is not particularly deadly for people
who are under the age of 50.
so one of the things people need to
understand is base rates okay if one out
of a thousand people die
of the flu and two out of a thousand
people die of covet
the base rate is still really low right
that's still one in 500 people dying of
covet
but it is now twice as deadly as the flu
so it all depends on how you tend to
think about these issues
if you say i'm willing to undergo my
life i'm willing to i'm 36 right i'm not
in the under-20 crew
which means the covet is more deadly for
me than the flu am i willing to
hide in my house for the next year am i
willing to
never go out again am i willing to not
go shopping am i not willing to go to a
ballgame am i not willing to go to a
theater i'm not willing to go to a
restaurant am i not willing to do any of
those things for a year
on the chance that this thing has a two
in one thousand shot of killing me as
opposed to a one in one thousand shot of
the flu killing me
if i get it in the first place and the
answer i think for most people is no
which is why when trump said at the
debate that 99.9
of young people who get this live i
think that's the first that a lot of
people are hearing in that
the media have steadfastly refused to
talk about the actual
infection fatality rates on this disease
because they recognize that if they do
then people might might not be up for
the kind of societal shutdowns that
democrats are apparently calling for
okay but here's the bottom line there is
no solution being presented by the
democrats but in order for trump to lose
they have to pretend
like the solution is right here it's
right there and trump refuses to pick
that apple off the tree for some odd
reason from some meanie
from some bastard and trump wants you to
die right that is the final pitch for
democrats this has actually been their
pitch
throughout covet trump is not only
incompetent and his incompetence has not
only ruined lives he's malevolent
republicans are malevolent and they are
and if democrats are elected they will
have a plan you hear this from biden and
harris all the time we have a plan they
don't have a plan
they don't okay the plan they have
presented thus far is exactly the trump
plan what if we like developed a vaccine
right trump's doing that
what if we ensured that ppe was
delivered to hospitals personal
protective equipment
trump's done that well you know what
what if we urge social distancing and
mask wearing
okay well every state in the union is
doing that and regardless of what trump
says all of his public health officials
are saying that as well
including the much-maligned dr scott
atlas who came on the program last week
and did exactly that
it's not that democrats have a different
plan than republicans it's that whoever
was president of the united states
because the president
is seen in america for some bizarre
stupid reason
as a god-like figure capable of writing
all wrongs whoever is president is going
to reap the whirlwind of a very bad
thing happening and democrats are simply
going to lie to you that the president
wants those bad things to happen in the
first place okay all this came to a head
over the course of the weekend because
the white house chief of staff went on
national television and he was talking
about the pandemic
and he said that we are not going to
control the pandemic we're going to
focus on mitigation and this apparently
is a world shattering statement that
we're not going to control the pandemic
we are going to focus on mitigation
okay let me make this absolutely 100
clear nobody is going to control the
pandemic
the only way to control the pandemic is
to have a very very low level of seating
in your society has happened
in east asia and then to have massive
testing regimens
at that time massive masking and
mandatory quarantine those are the only
ways that you were going to get that
under control and that would be if you
had a zero percent seating right if the
seating were unbelievably low
right now in the united states we are
experiencing
as of yesterday 60 70 000 new cases
a day a day okay there is no way to get
that and community spread
massive community spread across the
country there is no way
for us to quote unquote stop the spread
that is not going to happen
okay the only way that the spread is
going to stop is when it burns itself
through when a lot of people have had it
because
or a vaccine is developed that's it
there is no third way you can slow the
spread
by social distancing and wearing masks
you can prevent that spread
unintentionally to people who are
elderly by shielding and protecting the
elderly but nobody
not democrats not republicans nobody is
stopping the spread
and if you don't believe me ask europe
where the thing is spreading like
wildfire
anyway here was mark meadows saying
something perfectly obvious and then the
media using this
as an excuse to say well if it were else
we'd stop the spread really
explain seriously explain i want to hear
how you gonna stop the spread
how you gonna do it italy had a
mandatory mass mandate outdoors as of
early october italy's getting walloped
right now
tell me how you're gonna do it tell me
epidemiologists at cnn how you're gonna
do it
anyway here was mark meadows saying a
bad bad thing when he mentioned
the absolute baseline fact that in a
country of 330 million people with tens
of thousands of cases of a virus
spreading a day and this thing is three
times as spreadable as the flu
you're not simply going to be able to
stop the spread that is perfectly 100
obvious okay anyway here's mark meadows
saying a a perfectly obvious thing and
then we'll see the media
using that as an excuse to suggest that
trump wants people to die
here's what we have to do we're not
going to control the pandemic we are
going to control the fact that we
get uh vaccines therapeutics and other
mitigations why are we going to get
areas
because it is a contagious virus just
like the food but why not make
efforts to contain it well we are making
efforts to contain it by running all
over the country not wearing a mask
that's what the vice president
back and forth let me just say this is
what we need to do is
make sure that we have the proper
mitigation factors whether it's
therapies or vaccines or treatments
to make sure that people don't die from
this okay meadows happens to be exactly
right about this and jake
who i like but jake is absolutely wrong
about this this idea that you're going
to quote unquote contain
the virus yeah good luck with that okay
i'm just going to read you some stats
from italy in one second
and um let's just say italy's been
locked down
it ain't working we'll get to that in
just one second first it is halloween
this month policy genius would like to
mark the occasion by making something
less scary for you
life insurance shopping for life
insurance can seem like a daunting task
but policy genius makes it easy they
combine a cutting-edge insurance
marketplace with help from licensed
experts to save you time and money
right now you could save 50 or more by
using policy genius to compare life
insurance when you're shopping for a
policy that could last for more than a
decade the savings really do start to
add up here's how it works first
you head on over to policygenius.com in
minutes you can work out how much
coverage you need you can compare quotes
from top insurers and find your best
price
policy genius will compare policies
starting at as little as one dollar a
day
you might even be eligible to skip that
in-person medical exam once you apply
the policy genius team will handle all
the paperwork and the red tape
the best part they work for you not the
insurance company so if you hit any
speed bumps during the application
process
they'll take care of everything that
kind of service has earned policy genius
a five-star rating across over 1600
reviews
on trustpilot and google so if you need
life insurance which is a must-have if
you're a responsible human being head on
over to policygenius.com right now to
get started you could say 50
or more by comparing quotes policy
genius when it comes to insurance
it's nice and very very important to get
it right okay so
mark meadows says something absolutely
100 obvious which is that
we are not going to get this under
control this is a very very large
country with high levels of community
spread
and tapper is like well why can't we get
it under control i don't know why can't
italy get it under control
italy had as of october 25th 21 273
diagnosed cases of covet in italy okay
the population of italy
not close to the population of the
united states the population of italy is
60 million
the population of the united states is
330 million
okay so on a per capita basis they have
a higher rate of transmission than the
united states italy
is locked down italy was not open italy
had had
full-on mass m again i keep repeating
this because people apparently do not
want to understand
this okay the fact is once this thing
was widely seated
it was going to spread end of story and
the only thing you can do and really
where you should be putting your focus
is where you can save lives of course of
course
but this is the lie and the lie is going
to be promulgated by the media
that this is surrender so brian stelter
a reliable source he says that's the
sound of surrender
that if you say that you're not going to
control the virus
that you're going to have to learn to
live with it they're going to shield the
elderly
and that guess what reality is that
nobody's been able to control it
then apparently you're you're giving up
that's called giving up
i'm sorry this is anti-scientific
garbage it is anti-evidentiary
anti-scientific nonsense
and it is deliberately blind it's
deliberately blind it's funny when i was
talking to those media members about
trump's coveted handling versus
democrats coveted handling
i would say to them so what would
democrats have done differently they say
trump they would have talked about masks
more i say okay
well there's virtually no masking in
northern europe there's a lot of masking
in southern europe both have been
walloped
so you're gonna have to explain to me
how talking about masking more
really would have changed the trajectory
of this thing especially given the fact
that democrats were openly saying for
months that if you were protesting
george floyd's death
it was totally fine to go out there and
mack on people in the middle of a
protest of a million
i didn't see much blowback when there
were huge rallies
for the la lakers winning the nba
championship directly outside of staples
center with no masking where was the
massive blowback
it was gone weird hey in other words the
chances that
that you were going to stop the spread
through universal masking because the
democrats were telling you to
absolutely not okay that that's not true
okay also i mean again none of this is
anti-mask
i've been saying throughout the show and
for months that if you're in close
quarters with people you should be
wearing a mask and of course there's a
difference between the kind of masks you
wear
cloth masks are not nearly as useful as
surgical masks which are not nearly as
useful as
n95s or kn-95s okay but
the the notion that this thing was
eminently containable except for trump
is a lie and members of the media
it's an article of religious faith now
because if you ask them the question
they literally cannot tell you what
democrats would do differently they
can't because there's nothing democrats
who do differently but that is the
article of faith and every democrat cnn
is going to repeat it here's brian
stelter repeating it
that is the sound of capitulation by the
federal government
that is the sound of surrender trump
meanwhile sounds
bored with this leadership challenge
clearly he doesn't want the top story
to be about sick and dying americans
struggling with a virus that's out of
control
in part due to his government's failures
obviously he wants us talking about
hunter biden or fake news or
how mean 60 minutes is to him
and his base agrees but he is out of
touch with where the rest of the country
is
okay you are putting the rest of the
country in a position to believe
wrongly that trump is in a position to
snap his fingers and make this thing
stop that is not correct
and if by the way the democrats and the
media if biden is elected
immediately snap their fingers and then
all of a sudden we're stopping we're not
going to talk about covet anymore
it just shows what damned liars they
work because guess what cove is still
going to be out there
it is by the way germany right germany
was a model of how to stop the spread
germany had as of october 23rd almost 14
000 diagnosed cases
in germany so this thing is spreading
everywhere but again this is
this is the left-wing nonsense michael
moore said that donald trump is killing
off his own voters
any other president would have seized
the coronavirus
taken the reigns and tried to bend the
hero
especially when this was killing his
largest
demographic in 2016 was over 65. this
could get to 2500
deaths a day why trump would be killing
off
his voters uh historians and political
scientists are gonna have to figure this
out
uh in the future trump is not killing
off his voters chris
andrew chris cuomo's brother andrew
cuomo killed off the elderly voters
in new york gretchen whitmer in michigan
refusing to protect the nursing homes
again this is the it is it is a pretty
morally disgusting narrative that trump
is responsible for all of these deaths
the good news is that people at lincoln
project have no problem
pushing morally disgusting narratives so
they actually put up times square
billboards billboards in times square
about the evils
of ivanka and jared not even about trump
himself
right but ivanka and jared so they have
these giant billboards
one is a picture of ivanka trump smiling
and then it says
3 318 plus new yorkers
224 000 plus americans and she's smiling
like she's happy about it
like she's because that's ivanka right
ivanka's so evil that she wants
americans to die that's what she wants
ivanka desperately wants american sight
now
weird because what i noticed is that the
governor of new york is a democrat the
mayor of new york city is a democrat the
entire city council in new york is
democratic
that's what i noticed but apparently
it's ivanka trump's fault and not only
is it her fault
she revels in it that was next to a
giant smiling picture of jared kushner
saying new yorkers are going to suffer
and that's their problem okay that was
vanity fair unconfirmed denied by
kushner
it doesn't matter the lincoln project
runs with it because i mean have
have greater grifters been created than
the folks at the lincoln project
the definition of a grifter by the way
is somebody who knows what they're
saying is false but continues to say it
for the money
they know what they're saying is false
they continue to say it for the money to
try and con people into giving them cash
okay so all of this is now being
forwarded this this giant
narrative that we are seconds away from
a democrat taking office and getting
control of this thing
iron fist take control we'll get to that
in just
one second first let us talk about the
fact that
sometimes you need your employees to
really do their best let's say
that you left la weeks and weeks and
weeks ago let's say that you had
somebody who's in charge of your
security in la
and they were like you know what i'm
coming to where you're going to make
sure that you are safe and secure
and three weeks later you're sitting
there and you're like where is chad
and then all of a sudden chad shows up
he's all smiley he's all happy you're
like dude
where were you for three weeks like well
you know i had to i had to truck my
stuff across the country
and i stayed at some motels well then
you might think about
replacing chad and you head on over to
ziprecruiter.com
ziprecruiter.com will help you find the
world's best employees right now you can
try it for free
at zip recruiter dot com slash daily
wire first when you post a job on zip
recruiter it gets sent
to over 100 job sites with just one
click then zip recruiter's powerful
matching technology finds people
with the right skills and experience for
your job and actively invites them to
apply so you get qualified candidates
fast it is no wonder that four out of
five employers who post unzip recruiter
get a quality candidate within the very
first day right now
you can try zip recruiter for free at
ziprecruiter.com
dailywire that is ziprecruiter.com
d-a-i-l-y-w-i-r-e
zip recruiter dot com slash daily wire
you might be stressed out
but you can solve that stress by getting
better employees check them out at
ziprecruiter.com
dailywear try it out for free zip
recruiter is indeed the smartest way to
hire
okay so the narrative that is now being
pushed by democrats and by the media
again is that as soon as joe biden takes
place everything will be all better
so joe biden was interviewed on 60
minutes and joe biden was asked about
scott atlas and he basically said scott
atlas who is one of the doctors from
stanford
hoover institution who is telling trump
you know sort of his strategy
that's atlas is is not qualified for any
of this nobody agrees with scott atlas
now there's a word that i've been using
uh ultra crepitarianism
okay that is the that is the the ability
to speak outside
one's purview right the the idea here
from joe biden is that scott atlas is
not an epidemiologist so he shouldn't be
speaking about this stuff
okay there's only one problem with that
which is that joe biden is also not an
epidemiologist so you have to choose
which doctor you wish to
listen to and it turns out that there
are major epidemiologists who have
suggested exactly the same thing as dr
scott atlas
they are the authors of the great
barrington declaration which has been
actively downgraded by google
and by youtube and by facebook the great
barrington declaration
advocates for policy i've been
advocating for months which is protect
the elderly make sure that the elderly
and the infirm
are protected tell them to stay home get
all of them m95 masks make sure they
have what they need
and then if you're 20 years old then you
getting the virus should not only not be
treated as the end of the world
it should be treated as probably a good
thing in the long run for hurt immunity
because hurt immunity will be developed
one way or another
the great one of the great lies the
media tell about this sort of stuff is
that if you quote unquote advocate for
herd immunity you are advocating for
uncontrolled spread
that is not what herd immunity means
herd immunity is a product
herd immunity is something that happens
herd immunity happens when a certain
percentage of a population
gets a disease or a vaccine and then are
not capable of passing it along so the
reproduction rate drops below one that's
what herd immunity is
it's gonna happen whether you like it or
not it's gonna happen with vaccine or
it's gonna happen not with a vaccine
the only question is how you pursue herd
immunity and so what the great
barrington declaration guys say
and this includes martin kuldorf and jay
bhattacharya who's been on the program
one of them is from stanford
bhattacharya's from stanford
coldhorf is a biostatistician from
harvard who studies epidemiology
they they have said and they've joined
with sunatra gupta who's a professor of
epidemiology
at oxford right these are all
well-qualified people they've all said
that if you wish to pursue herd immunity
at the fastest possible clip
then what you need to do is allow 18 and
20 year olds to get this thing
and then you need to have them not come
into contact with older people
and then they can't pass it along to
other people right which is something
that i've been talking about since
literally i believe april when i started
talking about
so-called controlled avalanche strategy
which was a strategy that had been
pushed by a couple of scientists over at
hebrew university
okay that's an actual strategy but
democrats don't have a strategy the
democratic strategy is to suggest that
if you even mention hurt immunity you
are bad
that the only solution to this thing is
n is endless lockdown so here was joe
biden
ripping on scott atlas and suggesting by
proxy that he is going to
push for endless lockdowns dr scott
atlas
and he is advocating young people go
about their business
and older people sequester nobody thinks
he makes any sense
nobody no serious doc around the world
so joe biden says that nobody listens to
scott atlas nobody is saying that it
makes any sense to
to allow younger people to get it while
protecting the older elderly okay guess
what it's going to happen whether joe
biden likes it or not
it's going gonna happen whether joe
biden likes or not i was driving around
yesterday and one thing that i noticed
right i'm in south florida and one thing
that i noticed
i was driving around with my kids and we
drove past a a gym
okay and the gym was packed okay it was
packed with younger people
it was all younger people none of them
were wearing masks is that a good idea
if if any of those people are going to
come into contact with older people or
vulnerable people
it's not a good idea but are they going
to do it anyway absolutely
you think all the massive house parties
that are taking place in chicago or
miami
or la you think those are stopping right
now there's a reason why the death rates
are down there a couple reasons one
hospitalizations are going much better
but two young people are not nearly as
apt to be hospitalized for covet as
people who are elderly
and also young people are not going to
sacrifice entire years of their lives
and not do anything for a year because
joe biden tells them to it's not going
to happen
it's not happening in europe it's not
happening in the united states it's not
happening anywhere
so either you can set up a series of
restrictions that are doable
and you can try to set up some sort of
strategy for reaching herd immunity like
the great barrington folks
suggest or you can pretend that
everybody is going to mask up at
100 rates they're all going to know how
to handle their mass they're all going
to have high quality masks they're not
just going to be wearing
cloth masks that don't really do a whole
hell of a lot to protect you
from the transmission of the disease
they're only apparently according to
scott gottley because not me this is
former fda commissioner scott gottlieb
cloth masks are only about 10 effective
at preventing you from getting this
thing
you know the surgical mass is something
like 60 effective according to scott
atlas i mean according to a scott
gottlieb
and uh and n95s are 90 to 95 effective
in preventing you
from getting this thing is according not
to me to scott gottlieb
do you think people know that do you
think people are paying attention to it
huge majority of the people i see out
there are wearing cloth face masks or
neck gaiters
there are some studies suggesting that
gators are counterproductive
okay but again there's this myth the
myth is trump blew it
democrats will get this under control so
you end up with anthony fauci suggesting
over the weekend he's becoming more and
more openly political right he's
speaking out
openly obviously he's in the media he's
uh to uh to cnn and he said well maybe
it's time for a federal mass mandate yes
i'm sure anthony that'll make all the
difference doctor i'm sure dr fauci that
now
after in march you said nobody needed a
mask i'm sure that now that you say
everybody needs a mask not only do they
need a mask we're gonna we're gonna
punish them presumably
at the federal level we're gonna make a
federal crime not to wear a mask where
in a public place
and private with your family i'm sure
this will be highly highly effective
that'll finally get things under control
they have mass mandates across europe
i'm sure that's going to get it under
control dr fauci sure
sure if everyone agrees
that this is something that's important
and they mandate it and everybody pulls
together and say
you know we're going to mandate it but
let's just do it
i think that would be a great idea to
have everybody do it uniformly
one of the issues though you i i get the
argument say well if you mandate a mask
then you're going to have to enforce it
and that'll create more of a problem
well if people are not wearing masks
then maybe we should be mandating it oh
there we go so finally we reached the
the end point here maybe we should have
the federal government find or jail
people
if they refuse to wear their masks in
particular scenarios and here's the
question
where are you going to tell them to wear
the mask seriously on a scientific level
we're now realizing
that in certain countries 80 of all
transmission is being done in the home
you're going to mandate that people wear
masks in the home well good news
democrats are here for you gavin newsom
now says that you should wear a mask at
home according to newsweek ahead of
thanksgiving
california governor gavin newsom and the
california department of public health
released new safety guidelines for all
private gatherings amid the ongoing
covenant 19 pandemic
the new rules come with strict
restrictions that aim to help reduce the
risk of spreading infection
gatherings are defined in social
situations that bring together people
from different households
at the same time in a single space or
place when people from different
households mix
this increases the risk of transmission
of kovid 19.
all gatherings must include no more than
three households including hosts
and guests and must be held outdoors
lasting for two hours or less i
have a question why for two hours or
less we've been told you can transmit
this thing in 15 minutes
so why not 15 minutes or less seriously
what is the scientific
evidence that two hours or less is going
to be the great barrier here
and also i understand you want it
outdoors because it has better
ventilation
but they are now suggesting that if it's
like me and my parents i guess that is
two households
in the state of california so it's me my
parents and my sister and that is three
households
in the state of california i'm sure this
is going to be st and and
what what's going to happen the cops are
going to come knock on your door and
arrest you
or fine you if you get together with
family members on thanksgiving that's
yeah i'm sure this is going to be wildly
effective i'm sure you know what
you're right we need to elect joe
biden's that we can have the federal
officers come to your house if you are
in a house with you
and your parents and your sister's
family we need the feds at your door
if this sounds like a dystopian sci-fi
novel it's because we've basically
reached that point
according to what is now being requested
all in order to prevent the transmission
of a disease
that is not extraordinarily deadly for
people under the age of 70 but is
extraordinary
deadly for people who are above the age
of 70. okay which means
that last i checked we are all rational
and sentient human beings by the way
when i say extraordinary deadly i'm
comparing it to like extraordinarily
deadly diseases like ebola or the
bubonic plague
because the flu is not extraordinarily
deadly i'm not comparing it to the flu
before you know social media say i'm
coming i'm not comparing it to the flu
i've been very precise in my language
here
this is about three times as deadly as
the flu for people who are
between the ages of approximately 40 and
70. it's about twice as deadly as the
flu
for people between the ages of 20 and 40
and the reality is not that many people
die of the flu every year on a
population adjusted basis
so is it deadly yes is it highly highly
highly deadly in the mold of like
mirrors no it is not okay but we are now
going to have what federal officers
banging on your door if you get together
with some people over thanksgiving
and california is going to do this the
new rules state those at a gathering may
remove their face coverings briefly to
eat or drink
as long as they stay six feet away from
everyone outside their own household
and put their face covering back on as
soon as they are done with the activity
the latest guidelines at face coverings
can also be removed to meet urgent
medical needs
the existing face coverings also set out
by the cd ph also apply they say
everyone must wear face coverings in
high risk situations
including in outdoor public spaces when
maintaining a six feet distance outside
from those outside your household
is not feasible also no singing no
chanting no shouting
and uh you should participate in quiet
activity
musicians are allowed at gatherings but
they must be from one of the three
households also no playing of wind
instruments
so uh yeah this is all going to go great
i'm sure everybody is going to abide by
this in california
i'm sure that every single person is
going to abide by this in california by
the way the state with the most
confirmed
coveted cases in the united states
california with 855 000 confirmed
coveted cases despite massive
lockdown restrictions and all of this
covid talk is predicated on the notion
and if you just flip a switch it goes
away and that switches trump that is a
pagan
silly notion it is not true it is simply
not the case
okay in a second we're going to get to
joe biden and the biden
campaign because he continues to surge
in the polls even though he
again has not done nearly any media he's
called another lid today i believe
we'll get to that in just one second
first let us talk about the fact
that you hear these ugly stories all the
time right a good guy uses a gun to
protect his family from criminals and
then he gets arrested
well sometimes the legal system isn't
fair and responsibly armed americans
could become political targets which is
why you really need to know
what you can do legally and what you
can't do legally and also you better
have some legal defense at your disposal
if god forbid you have to fire your gun
in order to protect yourself here's how
you can take a simple powerful journey
to firearms and self-defense confidence
it's called the complete concealed carry
and family defense guide from the united
states concealed carry association
that's the uscca it is 100 free
you'll learn how to detect detect
attackers before they see you
how to survive a mass shooting the
safest and most dangerous places to sit
in a restaurant how to responsibly own
and store a gun even if you got little
kids and a whole lot more it is 164
pages it comes with a bonus audio
version so you can listen
whenever you want just text bend to 87
222 again
text ben to 87 222 you'll get instant
access and a chance to win a thousand
bucks so you can buy a gun to protect
your family text ben
to 87 222 right now text ben to 87 222
to get instant access to that family
defense guide concealed carry and family
defense guide from the usca good folks
go check them out right now okay we're
gonna get to
more on the presidential race in just
one second
first 2020 has been insane yeah and if
it feels like things are coming apart
it's because they really are we have
massive philosophical differences that
are now coming to a head in the united
states joe biden's been trying to gloss
over them
with his magical ads that are basically
just stock footage of a farm and then
stock footage of a baseball game and
then him being like
america okay but here's the reality the
democratic party and many in the
democratic party now represent a
viewpoint
that is at odds with the philosophic
foundings of the united states they do
not believe
in the negative rights guaranteed by the
declaration and the constitution of the
united states they believe that american
history
is a roll call of evil they believe that
american culture a culture of
entrepreneurialism and tolerance for
others rights
is wrong-headed because it allows for
the success of the evil
okay i write about all of this in my
book how to destroy america in three
easy steps which isn't just a takedown
of a leftist view of america that
america is bad it is also a reminder of
what makes america so very good why the
declaration's ideals are correct why the
constitution is properly structured
why it is that the culture of the united
states forwards tolerance
and entrepreneurialism and why american
history is a story of good
punctuated by great periods of evil but
of america striving to fulfill her
founding principles
go pick up a copy right now how to
destroy america in three easy steps it
is going to be a primer for if god
forbid joe biden wins the election it is
going to be a primer
for how to fight back go check it out
right now how to destroy america in
three easy steps also in case you missed
it yesterday
we had on another great episode of the
sunday special this time it was jared
kushner apparently he's responsible for
all kova deaths in new york according to
the lincoln project
he is senior adviser to president trump
jarrett joined the show to share his
experience with the president
and to remind the american people of the
administration's accomplishments that
will continue for four more years if
donald trump is re-elected it was a
great conversation i hope you enjoyed it
head on over to dailywire.com right now
you can listen on apple podcast spotify
or wherever else you get your podcast
also as you know the presidential
election is almost here we have an
amazing day of programming planned for
you
our live stream starts on election day
tuesday november 3rd 3 p.m eastern 12
p.m pacific we're gonna go
until the cows come home featuring
special guests live interviews multiple
all-access live sessions
leading up to a very special episode of
backstage where we will be covering the
results with you in real time even
better
join daily wear right now get 25 with
code election
25 off you can watch all of our election
coverage live on our apple tv or roku
app
members get our articles add free access
to all of our live broadcasts and show
library
the full three hours of the ben shapiro
show exclusive readers past content
available only to daily wire members
if you're considering an all-access
membership you get to join us on all
access live every night for online and
live stream discussions
you also get not one but two leftist
tiers tumblers with your membership as
well as early sometimes exclusive access
to those magical new daily wire products
so
watch the election with us at
dailywire.com get 25 off your daily wire
membership with code election
when you sign up today you're listening
to the largest fastest growing
conservative podcast and radio show on
the nation
[Music]
a quick final note on democrats covet
talk here so over the weekend five
people in mike pence's office
tested positive for covid 19. and um
the basic idea from the media is that
mike pence should take himself off the
campaign trail which is weird because
you know who actually didn't do that was
kamala harris
right so if you're on the other side
apparently nobody cares if you do it
right members of kamala harris's team
got sick with covet
and there was no repercussion nobody
suggested hey wait a second this thing
seems like it's really really
transmissible
and even though people in the biden
harris team are wearing masks
it still seems like a lot of people are
getting this sort of thing instead of
being realistic about covet in other
words
we have decided in our minds that we are
going to do what every
listen it's understandable it's a
understandable human reaction to tragedy
when bad things happen our first
reaction as human beings is to
try to spot the differentiating feature
so that that tragedy will never happen
to us
that's why when you hear that somebody
died at a young age the first thing you
say is what did they die of
and if they say that they died of cancer
the first thing you say is well did they
smoke
right did they did they have heart
disease did it run in their family in
other words you try to look for the
reason why it's not going to hit you
why you are going to be immune to the
virus right when you watch a zombie
apocalypse movie the first thing you
think is oh i'd be the guy who survived
probably not okay now the reality is
when it comes to covet we're doing the
same thing
right we're saying to ourselves okay
well if i wear the mask then i'm
definitely
i'm definitely not gonna get this thing
okay here's the reality you'll lessen
your chances
you may very well get the thing okay if
you stay away from other people
you lessen your chances of getting
covered you may very well get the thing
nothing is foolproof here you can take
cautious action and i've ripped into
trump when i think he has not taken
cautious action i've been very much
against these rallies
i've been very much against these
open-air events where people are not
masked i think their stupid idea
but that does not mean that the
democrats have any broad
scale solution to this entire thing but
here's the thing the coveted narrative
allows everybody to escape having to
talk to joe biden about issues regarding
joe biden
you realize that kamala harris has not
done a single press conference kamala
harris will be president of the united
states if joe biden is elected
joe biden is on his last legs it is
perfectly obvious to anyone who watches
him for any period of time
that joe biden is on his last legs
kamala harris
has not done a press conference not one
since she was nominated for the vp not
one
if this were flip side don't you think
that perhaps the media might be asking
questions about it but here they are so
willing to
go along with whatever allows joe biden
to be elected the media are the real
story of this election
at least they will be after the election
if biden wins the story here is not
going to be that biden ran a wonderful
campaign
the story here is going to be two-fold
that trump blew it for himself because
he couldn't
shut his app and that the media are the
worst things in american life that the
media
are the overt partisan wing
communications wing of the democratic
party
because apparently they're just not
going to cover stories now
in fact it's bad to cover stories now
it's it's amazing
very few members of the media will ask
anything about hunter biden or joe biden
so where do we stand on the hunter biden
joe biden stuff okay so what we know
from the emails and from the texts is
that hunter and james
james is joe's brother were pursuing a
business deal in china
with a group called cefc china
cefc china initially said it was going
to send 10 million bucks in early 2017
to a joint venture including hunter and
uh and james
they focused on trading oil futures and
securing the rights to overseas oil
fields and strife torn places
like chad south sudan and iraq one early
version of their business plan indicated
that hunter and james biden and their
american associates have forged
alliances with the highest levels of
government
banking and enterprise it was perfectly
obvious to everybody by the way that the
reason
that hunter and james were being
included is because of their proximity
to joe because hunter and james have no
qualifications otherwise
now that doesn't necessarily mean that
joe was in on the arrangement
or that he was making money from the
arrangement or that he was involved in
the deal
prior to when he left the vice
presidency
he says he didn't know anything and he's
never received any money the deal itself
ended up canceled
but there's no question that joe looked
the other way as members of his family
trafficked in his name
for years on end which is indeed it may
not be criminal but it's certainly
corrupt if you're a member of the
government and members of your family
are jet-setting around the earth
telling foreign leaders and telling
foreign corrupt oligarchs
that they have access to you and that
you have purview over their
over their foreign policy i mean that's
pretty corrupt stuff
in fact even the new york times is
reporting now
that the joint venture here was at least
partially predicated
on joe biden and joe biden's proximity
to power
according to the new york times the
documents show that the countries hunter
biden james biden and their associates
plan to target for deals
overlapped with nations where joe biden
had previously been involved as vice
president
one 42-page plan includes a section
specifically highlighting former vice
president biden's role in facilitating
increased commerce with colombia which
is one of the targets of the joint
venture
along with luxembourg oman and romania
again hunter biden's role in that china
deal was key in the relationship set up
messaging the goodwill around the
chairman referring to yi zhan ming
the chairman of cefc we still don't have
any answer from joe biden
as to whether one text message that
suggested that or one email that
suggested
that 10 was being held in escrow for the
big guy who the hell the big guy was
okay these are all open questions they
should be asked of joe biden obviously
mainly because biden has portrayed
himself as clean as the driven snow he
has said that hunter has never done
anything corrupt which of course is very
very silly
now if you're on fox news then
presumably you'll get a reporter or two
who'll ask the question chris wallace
asked gretchen whitmer the governor of
michigan
doesn't biden owe a fuller account of
his son's business dealings while he was
vp
whitmer of course has no answer there is
evidence
it may be that biden didn't take money
but clearly
uh his brother his son were involved in
business dealings there was talk
about the biden name uh one
wasn't that inappropriate for that to be
going on while he was vice president
sure sounds like influence peddling
and doesn't he owe a fuller accounting
you know chris i think that uh joe has
sat for
questions he has answered these
questions the american people aren't
going to be distracted
oh they're not going to be distracted so
he doesn't have to answer any of the
questions weird okay so tom cotton
uh was um was on with andrew ross orkin
on cnbc and ross sorkin was asking him
uh about
why he should report the story he's
saying we can't corroborate any of the
emails
and cotton's like okay hold up a second
so now your standard for reporting is
that you have to be able to corroborate
the underlying evidence
didn't you guys run for like years with
the russia crap and you didn't
corroborate a single fact about it
you're talking about the tech companies
censoring
such quote unquote news if in fact
the tech companies had quote unquote
liability like news
operations do you you wouldn't want them
to be reporting something that they
couldn't corroborate no
do you mean like the russian collusion
hoax and the still dossier that you
reported on for four years andrew
okay yeah that would be the end of that
particular conversation but again the
new standard for the media is if we
can't corroborate it we're not reporting
it
which is not their standard it's not
even close to their standard because
guess what's not corroborated
you know you can't corroborate unnamed
sources no way to corroborate them in
fact we know the sourcing on the hundred
biden emails
way better from the new york post than
nearly anything that's been reported in
the mainstream media about russia or
collusion or ukraine
for years on end nonetheless the
standard for the media it's new it's a
new standard
the media are overt partisans on behalf
of joe biden it is insane
nbc news reporter ben collins he
actually tweeted out
reminder for your uncle the press can't
cover hunter's hard drive because we
don't have access to it this isn't a
wikileaks thing
one guy has access to it he wouldn't
give it to us and now he's in
quasi-hiding because he got caught
in a hotel room with borat's daughter
right talking about rudy giuliani not
turning over the hard drive
to nbc for example but weird because i
don't remember you having any access to
any of the underlying material in nearly
any of the stories you've reported
about russiagate for literally years on
end so the standard
is magically morphing it is magically
changing
my favorite line of the weekend actually
came courtesy
of thomas ridd a professor of strategic
studies at johns hopkins university
school of advanced international studies
he had a piece in the washington post
this is a direct quote you ready we must
treat the hunter biden leaks as if they
were a foreign intelligence operation
even if they probably aren't even if
they probably aren't
so now we have to just ignore them and
not report on them
even if they're legit because we have to
work under the assumption that anything
said bad about democrats must be russian
disinformation
all of which allows joe biden to simply
treat reporters like garbage when he's
asked about it he was joe biden over the
weekend
being asked about hunter biden and just
cutting him dead
questions the controversy continues
today about underbinding your sons
there is no controversy about my son
it's all a lie it's a flat lie because
the president has nothing
else to run on if you notice and while
american people are talking about what's
happening to their families
he has no plan and the debate he has no
plan everything from the wall street
journal
every other major news outlet has said
what he's
saying is simply not true about my son
but it's
classic trump classic trump
okay except for the fact that um
actually the emails are real
and the texts are real and people are
asking legit questions about them but
the good news is he can just shout
coveted masks
and everybody goes oh well he knows the
solution guys everything will be better
tomorrow
if that evil malevolent force donald
trump is out of office again all this
also allows joe biden to escape from the
fact that
he is not with it okay now he can get
he's not to say he can't get through a
sentence he can get through a sentence
and get through several sentences he
can't get through like a full paragraph
without starting to lose it
okay over the weekend over and over and
over joe biden was just gaffing all over
the place
now one of these gaffes would have
killed any other candidate
seriously any other count mitt romney
you remember what about your gaffes
people
yelling at mitt romney as though mitt
romney were half as senile as joe biden
appears to be on the verge of being
okay i'm old enough to remember when
people took gaffes seriously so long as
they were coming from republicans
i mean we still remember all of george w
bush's guests right edumacation
remember that one edumacation we still
remember dan quayle misspelling potato
right these were major gaffes
joe biden mixes up which office he is
running for
he mixes up which state he is in he
mixes up the candidate he is running
against
over the weekend he suggested he was
running against george
i assume he means bush not george of the
jungle but guess what bush has been out
of office since 2008.
here is biden mistaking trump for bush
this is the most consequent not because
i'm running
but because who i'm running against it's
the most consequential election
uh in a long long long time
and the character of the country in my
view is literally on the ballot
what kind of country we're gonna be four
more years of george uh
georgia he uh gonna find ourselves in a
position where
if uh trump gets elected uh we're gonna
be uh we're gonna be in a different
world
that wasn't the only one then joe biden
brags about having the most expensive
voter fraud organization in history
again these are these are gaffs that
would any other candidate these would
all be headlines
but it's protect the precious time now
right we're in the final days of the
election protect the pressures even if
that precious
is a daughtering coot who's not going to
be in office for four years let alone
eight here's joe biden
we're in a situation where we have put
together
and you guys did it for our
administration the president obama's
administration
before this we have put together i think
the most
extensive and inclusive voter fraud
organization in the history of american
politics
that's exciting he's put together the
most extensive voter fraud organization
in the history of american politics
you want to get those conspiracy
theorists going that would be the way
that you do it
and again the good news is that for the
democrats
nobody is going to ever have to answer a
tough question because they're democrats
so kamala harris was on
60 minutes and she broke up that joker
laugh i mean the crazy joker laugh a lot
so kamal harris
has this really bad tell if you're ever
asked to play poker with kamal harris do
it
because if you ask her if she's got a
pair of jacks she will just be like
i mean it's wild it's like she is going
to it's like she has set up
two separate crime scenes and then she
has to direct batman which one to go to
it's
it's crazy so here was here is kamala
she was asked about her perspective and
she's asked whether she's a socialist or
a progressive
and apparently this is just damned
hilarious i mean absolutely hilarious
she breaks into a laugh i mean this is a
laugh right here
i promised joe that i will give him that
perspective and always be honest with
him
and is that a socialist or progressive
perspective no
no it is the perspective of of a woman
who grew up a a black child in america
who was also a prosecutor who also has a
mother who arrived here at the age of 19
from india who also you know
likes hip-hop what do you want to know
man hilarious hilarious by the way she
was then asked a follow-up question so
you're the most um
the most liberal member of the united
states senate and she lost it again
i mean this bleep is freaking hilarious
right i mean it's like she's watching a
chris farley movie over here
i mean she's asked whether she is a
liberal and uh
it's a very easy question right they ask
you're the most liberal member of the
united states senate and she's like
oh that's just mike pence who says that
and the reporter's like well no
actually that's gov track and she's like
well the good news is that democrats can
always count on their friends all they
need is a little help
from their friends speaking of which
okay so social media over the over the
past
several weeks has become very open and
obvious in their desire
for donald trump to lose the election
okay
corporations social media and this is
all virtue signal and garbage so what
what corporations have decided is
they've decided that a huge number of
americans are buying products based on
political preference
they've decided that it is better to go
along with the woke
than it is to simply stay silent because
the woke demand they demand
answers right now there is no luxury to
stay silent as we found out about chris
pratt
the actor last week if you stay silent
silence is complicity
and so you're mandated to say something
and people want this for corporations
too
this is how you end up with the ceo of
expensify
which is a service that helps you
basically do your expense reports
he sent an email to 10 million customers
on thursday
demanding that they vote against donald
trump and for joe biden
he sends out this this giant email which
of course received plotted from the
media now imagine
if the head of walmart sent out an email
to all of the walmart employees and said
i need all of you to vote for donald
trump because otherwise joe biden is
going to wreck our business and you're
going to end up
either fired or with a lower wage right
our business will go down and there will
be consequences that
the media would lose it lose it in fact
the media did lose it when companies
started sounding off about how obamacare
was going to damage their business which
it would
it was how dare they they hate obama
that's what this is about but everybody
cheers like seals because the expensify
ceo
put out this nasty email about how you
need to vote for joe biden quote
i know you don't want to hear this from
me yeah you got that damned right and i
guarantee i don't want to say it but we
are facing an unprecedented attack on
the foundations of democracy itself
if you're a u.s citizen anything less
than a vote for biden is a vote against
democracy
weird because you know what i heard
about joe biden is that he wishes to
pack the supreme court that he wishes to
kill the filibuster and he wishes to
stack the senate with his friends
so um that seems like not super
democratic or super republican small or
republican
david barrett says that's right i'm
saying a vote for trump a vote for a
third party candidate or simply not
voting at all they're all the same
they're all the same so if you choose
not to vote for either or if you choose
not to vote because you find them that
they both stink
they're both the same you are now an
enemy of democracy
you are you are like the germans who sat
by and watched hitler take power
they're all the same and they all mean
quote i care more about my favorite
issue than democracy
i believe trump winning is more
important than democracy i am
comfortable standing aside and allowing
democracy to be methodically dismantled
in plain sight if the polls are accurate
there's a roughly 50 chance you agree
trump needs to go
you know what to do show up on november
3rd and vote for biden
and i love these uh he then puts out
this little q a okay here's here's some
of the q a you ready
why do you care so much about democracy
i mean this is like when somebody asks
you in a job interview what's your
what's your worst quality you say i'm
too diligent
why do you care so much about democracy
david asks david i care so much about
democracy because i'm just that kind of
guy
democracy is core to our business
success in a variety of ways
internally we are a famously flat
organization nobody reports to anybody
else
an advancement is the result of meeting
well-defined criteria
as judged by the vote of those who have
already advanced
we are we are a democratic company
really okay so what if they vote you out
you'll be happy with that how's that
gonna go for you david are you the head
of the company
he says what gives you the right to tell
me what to do the first amendment to be
clear you don't need to listen
but the first amendment exists to
encourage people like you and
me to find some way to talk about the
issues that matter
the burden of democracy is that this is
literally our job
so i'm asking all of us to take it
seriously and he says
expensify depends on a functioning
society and economy
as ceo of this business it's my job to
plot a course through any storm
and four more years if trump will damage
our democracy to such an extent i'm
obligated on behalf of shareholders to
take any action i can to avoid it
he says he's he's not sure democracy can
survive a trump presidency
don't you think you're exaggerating no i
truly wish i was
i wouldn't be sending this email if the
election were just about normal issues
but it isn't this election is a
referendum on what limits venue
we place on our elected officials to
govern us in a fair and representative
way and then you talk about voter
suppression we're gonna have more votes
in this election than any election in
american history
bar none the early turnout is insanely
high and this idiot's talking about
voter suppression still
okay like all of this corporate america
has decided to mobilize on behalf of the
woke
and then social media has decided to
mobilize
on behalf of democrats and the media
have pushed this along now let's make no
mistake there is this feedback loop it
exists in the media
whereby members of the media so-called
journalists act as activists people like
kevin roose at the new york times
people like kara swisher at the new york
times people like jugg lagamba goomba
gum right they all put out these reports
about how social media
by being so tolerant toward right-wing
views has allowed trump to win
well we near what we need is threat bear
democracy
right which is this policy in germany
that bans neo-nazi parties we need
something like that but for the right
we need to make sure that social media
never allows right-wing views to be
promulgated and then
when people on the right sound off about
it then we say well conservatives keep
complaining about social media look how
they're working the refs
okay guys you've been working the refs
for years you've been threatening
legislation against social media i've
been the one saying i'm against
legislation with regard to social media
and you guys have been pressing for
legislation
and you've been pushing them not subtly
at all to shut down the methods of
distribution
for outlets that are not mainstream
quote unquote outlets if it's not the
new york times cbs or abc you want it
done
you're angry about it and when we sound
off when we say
hey look at this it looks like they are
shadow banning us it looks like they
just banned the twitter account of the
new york post
for a week and a half it looks as though
you're suppressing our ability to
distribute by the way we can tell you
think we can't tell our own traffic
we can tell when social media is
downgrading us it's happening this week
in real time
in the run-up to the election but if we
complain about it then we are told
oh how dare they complain about social
media so cnn has a piece today
say it says a right-wing offensive is
underway to discredit social media
companies just days before the election
what began as complaints about
anti-conservative censorship by social
media companies
has now evolved into outright
allegations of election interference
well i mean yes because you literally
said that you would not report any of
the hunter biden allegations pending a
fact check
you still have not ruled anything false
in the new york post stories and twitter
is still banned the new york post yes
that is election interference
it is overt it is not covert it is not
subtle but according to cnn
outside experts have found little
evidence to support claims of widespread
systematic political bias
in silicon valley's technology but the
conservative allegations are an
explosive charge and a dramatic
escalation
ahead of election day okay so this is
hilarious so now they're taking the
perspective that silicon valley is not
biased against conservatives
okay but you're simultaneously arguing
in places like cnn and the new york
times
that silicon valley is biased in favor
of conservatives i can't tell you the
number of pieces that have been written
over the course of the last six months
about how daily wire is bad and evil
because we are highly trafficked on
facebook and what you will see
is people putting out these charts
suggesting that our engagement at daily
wire is really really high on facebook
right because we write good headlines
that's why
but apparently it's because social media
is biased in favor of daily wire
i'm sure that's what's happening i'm
sure that's exactly what's happening
there's only one problem
it is a lie okay so i want to go through
this for a second because it's actually
important
by using this lie by promulgating this
lie the media
have created this feedback loop here's
how the loop goes the new york time
claims
social media is biased against
conservatives then social media
in obesity to the new york times says
okay we're going to downgrade social
conservatives
then conservatives say you're
downgrading us then the media say look
at these paranoid conservatives saying
that they're being downgraded
how dare they how dare they
and then they say look at these
right-wing sites they you know you can
tell they're bad you can super tell
their bad because they keep repeating
each other's messages
this whole loop it's this whole circular
logic bull crap
so let's break it down for just a second
these charts that go around
generally from places like newswhip
showing the kind of engagement that
various
sites get okay so the top 10 web
publishers on facebook
for the last month for example it showed
daily wire at the top i think it was for
august
it showed that we had 1 000 articles and
then we had 78 million facebook
engagements
so our per article engagement was really
high the reason it was really high is
because our people write fantastic
headlines
and because there is not a lot of great
conservative content
out there the number of conservative
sites as we'll see is actually pretty
low
you'll see the breitbart is number six
on this list fox news is number two in
daily mail is number three
but you'll notice that many of the other
sites on this list are left wing
cnn nbc news new york times npr the hill
okay so why is it that conservatives are
getting that sort of of
engagement the reason is because there
are fewer right-wing publishers than
there are left-wing publishers
in the top 25 publishers on facebook 16
are of the left
nine are of the right well if there are
50 of people who want conservative
content
and 50 percent of people who want
left-wing content then those aren't
going to split evenly
right if you have more left-wing outlets
than right-wing then right-wing outlets
what you are likely to see is that the
left-wing outlets each get
less engagement than the right-wing
outlets but overall get more engagement
which of course is precisely what you
see
of the total engagement 784 million
engagements
total engagements in the top 25
left-wing outlets received 409 million
engagements
right-wing outlets received 376 million
engagements it's actually left got more
engagement
than the wright did on facebook okay as
far as total likes which is a better
measure
total likes for the top 25 news outlets
68.4 were for the left they have nearly
two-thirds of the total likes
so while the new york times is about how
outlets like mine
are getting engagement on facebook many
of these outlets have more total likes
than anything remotely like what we've
got
it just happens to be we write good
headlines and there's an under supply of
conservative content which means that we
are over trafficked proportionately
speaking
but this is how all of this works all of
this is an attempt by the left to
suppress narratives they do not like
and they will use any cudgel at their
disposal and they do control
the controlling heights of the culture
this is why you end up with
pieces at the new york times today right
again this is that that not so subtle
pressure tactic quote
conservative news sites fuel voter fraud
misinformation breitbart the washington
examiner and others
amplify false claims of rampant cheating
in what a new harvard study calls a
propaganda feedback loop
they keep going back to this harvard the
this this sort of uh harvard institution
that uh is constantly writing about how
evil right-wing
sites are the berkman klein center for
internet and society these are the same
people who suggested that right-wing
youtube
directs people over to the alt-right
which is crap it's not true
okay many of us have overtly taken on
the alt-right and hit and gotten the
slings and arrows for it
doesn't matter again the idea here is
that if conservative sites repeat
information about possible voter fraud
they're bad but if left-wing sites talk
about how donald trump is going to steal
the election outright or remain in the
white house forever and they repeat that
same talking point
that's not a feedback loop at all
if you want to know by the way how these
narratives get created
all you have to do is look at how the
narratives get created around people
like sasha baron khan so baron cohen
right the borat guy he somehow turned
himself into this sort of cultural icon
with regard to politics though he knows
what the hell he's talking about he does
not
so again here is that that subtle
pressure not so subtle pressure coming
from the social left
here is sacha baron cohen this is back
in december suggesting that facebook is
bad because facebook allows material
sasha baron cohen doesn't like so it's
just like if they allowed material from
hitler
of course facebook does have policies to
crack down on neo-nazi material but that
doesn't matter to sasha baron cohen
because he's a damned liar so here he
was going after facebook for having the
temerity to allow right-wing content
if you pay them facebook will run any
political ad you want even if it's a lie
and they'll even help you micro target
those lies to their users
for maximum effect under this twisted
logic
if facebook were around in the 1930s it
would have allowed hitler to post
30-second ads on his solution
to the jewish problem the broader point
here is that sasha baron cohen is
treating everything on the right as
though it is hilarion
so not only is he historically ignorant
he also happens to
be a sensor himself he loves censorship
over the weekend
sasha baron cohen got mad because it
turns out he wrote a piece for i believe
it was newsweek magazine
in which they put a picture up of a
person wearing a mask said cove 19 is a
fraud
and the algorithm at facebook prevented
the dissemination of the article
because they said it was propaganda the
article of course was about how that was
dumb
and he got mad he said censorship is bad
oh i'm glad to learn that sasha cohen
bear and sasha baron cohen thinks that
censorship is bad now that's it that's
very very exciting stuff so censorship
is bad as long as it is applied to sasha
baron cohen it's very good when it's
applied to anyone else
by the way quick note quick final note
about sasha baron cohen
there's a piece in the independent today
talking about how sasha baron cohen has
avoided being canceled it is called
borat ii sasha baron cohen survived
cancel culture by
evolving instead of moaning okay well
what exactly did he evolve to he evolved
to the left that's all that happened he
came out as an open leftist he started
targeting
commonplace quote-unquote vulgar
right-wing americans
and the media decided not to cancel him
so that's the wonderful thing about
cancel culture you don't get cancer
you don't get cancelled if you are a
part of it which is why honestly points
to sarah silverman never thought that
would be a phrase i would say over the
weekend
sarah silverman she suggested that
cancel culture is righteousness porn she
is 100
about this without a path to redemption
when you take someone you found a tweet
they wrote seven years ago
or a thing that they said and you expose
it and you say
this person should be no more banish
them forever
they're going to find some place where
they are accepted do we want people to
be changed
or do we want them to stay the same to
freeze in
a moment we found on the internet from
12 years ago
and so we can point to ourselves as
right and
them as wrong okay the answer is
righteousness porn she is right she's
exact i can't believe this
she's exactly right about all of this
but it's not just that they're freezing
it in place
they're changing the standard every day
so they can freeze you in places that
you have to obey them
and they're preventing the dissemination
of material they don't like in order to
elevate their favorite candidates and
that's where we currently stand that's
the battle and it's gonna be a battle
long beyond this election it's gonna be
a battle for this entire generation
this is the battle to come okay whether
trump gets re-elected or whether biden
gets elected is irrelevant to this
battle
the media our cultural bettors they have
declared that you should not have access
to instrument information you like
that if you disagree with them you are
evil and you should be
and you should be suppressed and that
all of the methodologies of technology
corporate america social media
should be used against you this is what
they have decided and that is a battle
that is much bigger
than who gets to decide the next tax
rate on the top bracket in the united
states
alrighty we'll be back here later today
with two additional hours of content
otherwise
we will see you here tomorrow i believe
having all access live tonight actually
so go subscribe over at dailywire.com
you can hang out with me tonight
as you know the rules are t-shirts and
questions and bizarre behavior so go
check that out tonight at dailywire.com
this is the ben shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
colton haas our technical director is
austin stevens
executive producer jeremy boring our
supervising producers are mathis glover
and robert sterling
assistant director pava wydowsky our
associate producer is nick chien
the show is edited by adam syavets audio
mix by mike caromina hair and makeup is
by nika geneva
the ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 20.
hey everybody it's andrew clavin host of
the andrew clavin show
you know some people are depressed
because the american republic is
collapsing the end of days is
approaching
and the moon is turned to blood but on
the andrew clavin show that's where the
fun just gets started
so come on over to the andrew clayton
show and laugh your way through the
apocalypse with me
andrew clayton
you